Kevin Spacey won the best actor Oscar
for playing Lester Burnham in American
Beauty a middle-aged loser who's
inspired to take control of his life
after falling for a high school student
making things even worse she's his
daughter's best friend Angela Roger
Ebert noted correctly that the film
wasn't really about a Lolita
relationship but instead about yearning
after youth Respect power and of course
Beauty but Lester's fantasies about
betting a child are revolting you can't
help but agree with actress Kirsten
dunce who had the good sense to turn
down the role of Angela because she
quote didn't want to kiss Kevin Spacey
or be seen lying naked in those rose
petals after all she was only 15.